week 8 is here national football league
2020 season here's hoping that the next
10 weeks are pulled off without any
problems what can't you wait to see when
sunday rolls around
mike i'm old enough to remember when
le'veon bell played for the new york
jets and since we're the same age i know
you remember that too
it was actually a couple weeks ago of
course vaguely october 14th the jets cut
him and he signed with the chiefs went
from the worst team to the nfl to the
defending super bowl champions and now
he gets a play against his former team
everyone says this isn't le'veon against
the jets of course it's le'veon against
the jets we want to see what le'veon's
going to do against his former team and
i guarantee you he's going to be a
bigger part of the game plan and get
more touches than he did in his first
game for kansas city why this is going
to be a big levee on a game and i think
he's going to come up big for the chiefs
this week
yes six rushing attempts for 39 yards
against the broncos no catches but
there's no contest between the chiefs
and the jets the only source of intrigue
for this game is what le'veon bell does
what he may say
what sort of interaction there may be if
he
you know by way of the flow of the play
ends up toward the new york sideline
that's the only intrigue for this this
is one of the best teams in football
against one of the worst teams that we
have seen in the last
insert number of years i mean yes
there's been two oh and 16 teams since
2008 but the jets just aren't
competitive and the jets are two games
away from their bye week and it makes
you wonder what they're going to do
during their bye week but they've got
the chiefs they've got the patriots both
on the road and the only thing
intriguing about this game on sunday
is whether to what extent le'veon bell
will be used heavily and what he may say
or do during the game and what he may
say
after the game
first up for me
and we've been waiting for this ever
since the miami dolphins made tuatanga
valla the fifth overall pick in the 2020
draft we didn't know when
i thought it should have been week one i
think if you're gonna pick a quarterback
that high you need to be ready to use
him right away it was surprising that
after the dolphins move to three and
three when they blow out the 49ers and
then they beat the jets shut out the
jets they make the switch from
fitzpatrick to tua they had the bye week
to get two already now they've got the
rams coming to town and
i want to see what tua can do obviously
does he pass the eyeball test we didn't
see him in the preseason usually we get
that chance in august to see like last
year a kyler murray how does he look
against backups it doesn't matter it's
still nfl caliber talent how is he
is he is he just horrible or does he
look like he's really got it and that's
what we're going to find out from tua
pretty quickly and i don't rule out the
possibility of the dolphins winning you
got the rams going cross country on a
short week and brian flores the coach of
the dolphins knows a thing or two about
how to defend the rams because his last
game with the patriots came against the
rams in atlanta a game in which that
rams offense only scored three points
but two all eyes on him let's see does
he look as good as joe burrow and justin
herbert because he's the only one we
don't know yet whether or not he can get
it done
five total snaps he's played mike made
his debut last week and or two weeks ago
in mop up duty and went two for two in
in his limited action but we've been
waiting for this for a long time this
looks like a great rookie quarterback
draft just looks terrific and we want to
see him do the same things that we've
seen burrow and justin herbert do and
they've done it consistently
consistently and been very good this
year and i think tua is going to join
them and being very good for the
dolphins this is a tough matchup what i
do wonder mike this is a changed bye
week for the dolphins was this the plan
all along were they going to play him
and announce it before the bye week give
him the bye week to get ready and he
said he took uh watched extra film and
took extra snaps and all that but was
this the original plan and the date
moved up when the bye week changed
that's what we don't know i don't know
that that brian forest has been asked
that question but i would venture to
guess that that was the plan all along
and the bye week changed and they stuck
with their plan to give him the bye week
to get ready
that's a great point and as it was
originally scheduled the buy was the
sandwich between two games against the
jets so
a little easier to go with tuatanga
viloa coming out of the buy when you're
facing the jets a little bit harder when
it's the rams and i also would like to
know
how much of this decision is coming from
the top of the organization not that
stephen ross would ever pick up the
phone and say go with tua but one of the
privileges of being a billionaire is you
don't have to come out and say it you
can drop a hint and if the people who
work for you hope to continue to work
for you they may understand what you are
getting at all right next up shireen
what can't you wait to see on sunday
i can't wait to see mike and we're gonna
see this all year long is the browns
offense actually better without odell
beckham and all the browns this week say
disrespectful
disrespectful disrespectful
disrespectful you asked this question
absolutely and we heard it from jarvis
landry and baker mayfield and kevin
stefanski but here's the thing mike
the only way they can they can prove
that wrong is by going out and being
worse on offense and i just don't think
it's going to happen
i i think they're going to be really
good without odell beckham just like
they were without him last week against
the bengals you know baker was 22-23
after the first quarter when he went
over five almost 300 yards passing in
five touchdowns i just think it's going
to allow him to throw to the open
receiver
not worry about odell getting its
targets odell had the mo still has the
most targets of any player on the browns
roster and his second in catches i mean
he was trying to get him the ball just
to get him the ball and and that doesn't
always work and now he's able to spread
out the ball richard higgins is going to
take odell's place and he had over 100
yards after odell left i just think
they're going to be a better offense
without odell but they're going to prove
it one way or another as we go through
this year but i think they're going to
have a good week this week i've got no
problem with what any of the browns said
i would expect them to talk that way
what else can you say as members of the
organization but it's not disrespectful
for us in the media or us as fans to say
hmm you know
that whole odell thing
created a lot of stress on the offense a
lot of stress on baker mayfield and look
how he played once that weight was off
of him of having to maybe stare down
odell beckham jr a little bit longer
than he otherwise would instead of just
going through his reads and throwing to
the open man so we'll see and you're
right the only way that they are proven
to be accurate and what they're saying
is if they actually are worse and i
don't think they will be and this is
that one game this weekend for them it
falls into the category of i don't know
like the colts game they've won every
game they're supposed to win they've
lost every game they've supposed to win
and spectacular are supposed to lose
rather in spectacular fashion the colts
and the raiders are kind of like it
could go either way they still are
looking at 10 wins even if they lose to
the raiders if they beat the raiders it
could be 11 and 5 this year for the
cleveland browns i can't wait to see
what ben dinucci does for the dallas
cowboys starting quarterback sunday
night football welcome to the nfl ben
denucci seventh round draft pick out of
james madison what does he have what can
he do
and it was on a sunday night back in
2006 that we first saw tony romo in a
game against the panthers on sunday
night football now the difference is
romo had
three seasons
to develop
as the backup that no one really knew
about shereen i was new
at the time to this business it was
around 0304
someone told me they really love this
tony romo kid and my response was who
the hell is tony romo right because he
was undrafted out of directional
illinois and
there was no buzz there was no sizzle
but they loved him and remember when
sean payton went to new orleans in 2006
first order of business tried to trade
for tony romo and bill parcells
probably told him something profane but
the gist of it was no thank you
uh you know i i denucci doesn't have
that same
sizzle that same luster that same appeal
because he hasn't been there long enough
and we don't know what he can do he
didn't have an off season program so
i like the idea
of
just seeing what some guy that nobody
knows much about can do
but i don't have a good feeling for ben
dinucci on sunday night
yeah i don't either mike and andy dalton
is doubtful but he's not going to play
and jerry jones said today on his radio
show that he expects him to come back
next week but here's the thing mike we
didn't know much about dak prescott
either in 2016 right and it took an
injury to kellem moore in training camp
and then the preseason to tony romo he
comes out he wins the job so who knows
i'm not saying he's going to be the next
dak prescott but it took two injuries
for him to get the starting job now he
has as he says the chance of a lifetime
i listen to him uh talk this week and he
does not lack confidence i'll say that
he's ready to go and looking forward to
this opportunity but i'm not sure it's
going to go quite the way that dak
prescott's first start went for the
cowboys
there's actually plenty of intrigue this
week what's next on your list
i'm going to go back to that steelers
ravens game because i i do want to see
this game and i do want to see if the
steelers are for real i mean we think
they are right but you know ben
roethlisberger because there are the
only undefeated team we haven't talked a
lot about ben roethlisberger in the way
he's played he hasn't been great it's
been that defense that's really carried
this team and maybe it's time and maybe
this will be the week that ben really
has to make some plays and he almost
cost them last week with that
interception uh in the end zone made a
terrible decision thrown into double
coverage maybe triple coverage and gets
the pass tipped around and intercepted
uh and and frankly the titans should
have tied that game and taken it over
time but it's time for him to step up
and really be the guy that that we think
he is and he's been good he's certainly
been good enough it's an undefeated team
but they have lived feasted on that
defense i think at some point he's gonna
have to step up and make plays and this
may be the week i know it's a tough
defense but he's gonna have to make some
plays for the steelers to win this game
you know of all the teams with great
records in the nfl their quarterbacks
become de facto mvp candidates there is
not much talk about ben roethlisberger
as an mvp candidate even though the
steelers are the last remaining unbeaten
team in the nfl for me
and we talked earlier about it but this
is one of the most fascinating games of
the year the patriots going to buffalo
as the underdogs can they upset the
bills a question that has not been posed
in decades
and i think back
to
week one
2003
remember when the patriots cut lawyer
malloy right before the season
malloy signed with the bills and what
happened week one you remember the score
of that game week one two thousand three
patriots it bills
do you remember the bills won the game
right but i don't know 31 nothing
31 nothing
and that sparked the notorious tom
jackson line about the patriots they
hate their coach
uh
they would only win the next two super
bowls but
but you know if the patriot and that was
a stunner
when the bills won that game 31 nothing
it was a stunner it may have been 04
after the patriots had been defending
champions either way it was 0.304 i'm
gonna have to look it up now just to
satisfy my own curiosity but it was
viewed as a major upset it would be even
more shocking if the patriots would win
31 to nothing this weekend i i just it's
going to be stunning if they win at all
given how bad they've performed but this
sets up like the kind of game that the
patriots just come out and methodically
dismantle an opponent because we've seen
from time to time over the last 20 years
the patriots stumble and when they
stumble and everybody's ready to count
them out what do they always do shireen
they win remember the on to cincinnati
what happened to cincinnati they got
turned into mincemeat whatever mincemeat
is so
what's going to happen to the bills now
that the patriots are on the ropes that
is uh one of the most intriguing
prospects
of this week or any week of the
season it really is mike and i hadn't
realized it had been so long since the
bills won a division title 1995 but you
know they spent the entire offseason
talking about hey tom's gone we got our
chance now to win the division now's
your chance basics basically to
eliminate the patriots i mean it doesn't
technically obviously but it's going to
put them in a huge hole they're not
going to be able to dig themselves out
of but you're right we always see the
patriots rebound 2008 was the last time
this team didn't go to the playoffs and
they were still 11 and 5 had to play 15
games without tom brady 2002 last time
they didn't have double digit wins 2 000
was the last time they had a losing
record so this is a team that always
manages to win always manages to stay in
a race and frankly always manages to win
the afc east if the bills are going to
rule the east they're going to win this
game
if they if they're not going to rule the
east uh then the patriots are going to
reestablish that hey it still goes
through us it was 2003 the patriots
hadn't gone to the playoffs the year
before they were nine and seven and
didn't win the division but they did
lose 31-0 week one to the bills and then
the rematch came in week 17
the patriots won that game 31 to nothing
the ultimate bookend and then of course
they'd win the super bowl and the next
one and three more since then while the
bills are still trying to get back for
the first time since the 1993 season and
win their first one and there are real
questions about the bills over the last
three weeks because they aren't nearly
as good as they were the first four
weeks of the season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports